fue a través de un corto comunicado que
el Vaticano confirmó que el sumo
pontífice ha sido admitido en un
hospital Romano para ser operado en la
tarde de este miércoles el papa será
sometido a una laparotomía y a una
cirugía plástica de la pared abdominal
con prótesis una intervención quirúrgica
necesaria dice el Vaticano a causa de un
riesgo de obstrucción intestinal el
comunicado indica que Francisco sufre de
una hernia incisional encarcelada que
está provocando síndromes oclusivos
recurrentes dolorosos y que empeoran la
operación se desarrollará bajo anestesia
general el papa deberá permanecer
hospitalizado durante varios días
después de esta operación Este no es el
primer problema de salud del papa de 86
años en julio de 2021 fue operado de un
problema en el colon los médicos le
retiraron treinta y tres centímetros de
intestino y en marzo de este año estuvo
tres noches en el hospital por una
pulmonía aguda el papa también sufre de
problemas en su rodilla derecha que le
obligan a caminar con un bastón o en
silla de ruedas